[Music]
in awkward situation news Oh submitted
by talking llama como se llama hey a
cross-dressing Japanese boy goes viral
after a friend blackmails him for a date
why
how can you blackmail all across the
Japanese waiter that is normal like if
you don't go on a date with me I'm gonna
publicize you wearing a skirt pretty
much I know that [ __ ] was normal dog
this isn't like a day in Japan where
kids just cross stress anyways what
stress did what do they call stress they
just like dress up in like the girls
uniforms or so [ __ ]
is that what last time what kind of
blackmail was happening like you got to
have sex with me or else I'm gonna tell
the world that you're wearing girls
clothes it's worse than that
it's asking for a date it's like okay
let me why neodyne you take you out on
the town give you a night of your life
or I'll tell people that you dress like
a girl don't buy me steaks no blackmail
should be used for money or sex I
disagree with using it to debit nice
romantic dinner wrong I don't like it
it's too intimate Yeah right exactly
yeah it's like I just want to hold your
hands it's like mom I mean just lick
your balls dude come on this is but see
that's more direct yes I like that yeah
like I want to look in your eyes and
hold your hands like yeah yeah yeah come
on dude I I crossdress for fun so I
forgot what dating is like yeah I mean
like that without really a couple years
ago that you were dating right no but
man that [ __ ] was just burp yep this guy
just burped too and I was yelling at him
like what you guys are talking cuz I
could [ __ ] smell blowing burp Walt in
mid conversation and it kept going and
he just kept going this way though you
like when you've dated back in the day
psyche in my bag of the day like what
you did a brand new person like I forgot
what that feels like I don't know if I
liked it I think you know what's great
to hear is that you're happy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what's that like yeah so this this team
he's 17 years old so this Twitter user
posted photo like he posts photos of
himself dressed as a girl type um but
and his friend got horny because I
picture I picture like they're like if
it was me and David right and it David's
wearing a school go off and I'm like Oh
David but David does wear schoolgirl
outfits anarion is a little weak and it
wasn't that I never knew as well what
the [ __ ] but most most most guy friends
would say what the [ __ ] right yeah his
homeboy got really oh yeah yeah so that
17 year old bait he keeps it a secret
from all his friends the fact that he
likes to cross trip but he puts it
online yeah yeah but it's not his
personal Twitter it's like a Twitter for
like when he dresses its chin down like
you don't see the faces look fake and
how that's a pretty girl man just make
the best call a transgender trend like
cross dressers yeah yeah it's a given
she looks like she's 12 dude that's what
I don't know guys like no yeah 17 so
they're okay Japanese women should go to
jail don't say it right there but they
all look very young I'll say they are
high school kids right that's true she's
actually high school but I've seen some
ladies where I'm like BAM so yeah they
got a thicker mustache than mine and
then they have a wig on Oh
[Laughter]
I mean they look too young is that you
no no but I look 30 and they look like
they're like little schoolgirls whatever
100% like a buddy of mine has a wife
who's very tiny and I think you should
go to prison federal prison you know
what that what the Asian stereotype is
right like Asian women look like their
teens up until they're like 60 and all
of a sudden they turn into a sloth
turtle Oh
yes they never get into middle-age agent
don't raise and it just explodes they
just extrude they just turtle okay yes
then he ended up tweeting out that his
friend sent him a private message on a
popular messaging app called line and so
the conversation one like this do you
want to be a friend which am I am I the
guy of the girl this is his friend okay
hey
and then you uploads an image that's you
right huh
what what's this all of a sudden I mean
if you look at the room that's your home
I'm sorry got cut you find it revolting
I'll be honest okay what is it if you go
out with me I'll keep my mouth shut
what he actually did Wow
yeah so did you just forget that his
friend as a dick yeah what happened
that's all I'm saying
that's why I was laughing but they were
bracing themselves to be like okay I
know I'm wearing a skirt yeah what if
they fall in love and [ __ ] I think
that's what it is right now
cuz that's why I thought it was so funny
it's like your best friend you catch
them cross-dressing and you're like it's
my [ __ ] lucky day I already like you
as a person but now I think you're hot
see me if I knew that I was like
transacting with this person in a
conversation I know that that she could
get screenshot it I could get shake are
old right so what I'm gonna say is to
cover my ass at all points thinking like
a lawyer like thinking like an American
attorney I'm going okay we'll go on this
date and then she's like and then the
guy's like okay and then I'm like but no
dick [ __ ] I don't want your dick [ __ ] I
think that you're pretty looking as as a
one but I don't want diction and that
was that way later on if they were to
try to blackmail me back I'd like I said
no dick [ __ ] I just wanted the romance
that's right oh no you're still pretty
bad you're so interest free that can I
see that picture again
that was the him as a woman yeah it's a
very convincing woman because that'd be
like you dude that straight-up looks
like his arms feels like unfrozen otter
pop there's like no port
see him in his natural state I don't
have actual state I mean that looks like
a wig absolutely yeah sure like that
looks like you a doll we do the pose
down there like the body language which
what the eyes are so big yeah that's
crazy
I don't know wow yeah so then this tweet
went so lucky so we never found out if
we ended up going on a date there's no
follow-up so I'm not sure but someone
who read this whole Twitter conversation
they created a whole manga Wow about it
different Asians yeah out of all of us
you know they just such a unique Asian
subculture I can't wrap my head around
them right like they're just nothing
like Chinese people Korean people
they're just in their own world we're
out here we would just find out about
this and then like make fun of them all
over like Instagram and all the stuff
but this person makes a manga yeah it's
actually a genre I forgot the name of it
but always kiss I forgot the name of the
genre but what David Boies keep on
cross-dressing and yet this kind of
stuff it's a John rrah and manga I
forgot the name of it though oh my god I
think is it we'll just grab your laptop
and pull up your most recent history
like you didn't forget can't afraid okay
cuz you know poor Chan has all the anime
stuff yeah I was looking at every single
one because they had different names and
I was like why the hell is all of this
like cross-dressing romance well that's
a look at this Cloris Jesse romance up
now what the heck is up with all this
stuff let me go to I'm wearing a skirt
and I have a dick isn't this interesting
I think it is that one I think it is
called a yaoi
yeah we wasn't why a why why you I yeah
boy this bar meets before we're gonna
have sex
yeah definitely no but there's there's
there's girl girl
there's guy on guy and then there's guy
with cross-dressing guy and there's all
these different ones and then it just
fascinated me like this is an actual
Jarrah who's reading this stuff if it's
young women yes I was mindil that makes
sense to me he checked out the month
analytics so they take like those it's
like it's like a so there's a girl in
high school that really write like yaoi
comics and it was it's kind of like what
do you call those the American sex
novels type of thing romance
Danielle solution it's like the manga
version of that so you have these two
pretty boys that are suddenly like
kissing each other some [ __ ] but it's
like some gay stuff that they like with
two guys that they really think are
really cute in this comic book
dude YouTube why do you think I'm not
surprised here that's because on YouTube
it's all these little [ __ ] boys right
and they all have like shizzle looking
features but they're but they look like
feminine yeah and then these girls like
love these guys until they start to turn
into men where they hate they don't like
them in discard them into the [ __ ]
you know in the abyss but it's cuz
they're they're also young girls too so
16 year old and under they don't white
they don't why they don't want like
straight up to 40 year old men oh yeah
right well they don't want intimidating
features and intimidating like they like
the softer [ __ ] because you don't want
one that'll take your [ __ ] dad
exactly remember had the biggest crush
of [ __ ] me or not on DiCaprio when it
looked back on the video or the movies
that he was in that I was like oh my god
have my babies I'm like oh he look like
a woman yeah you look like a [ __ ] boy
yeah
interests yeah and it was just the most
interesting thing and they interviewed
these girls like why you like it
whatever they thought that forbidden
love or like a love between the same
gender or just whatever was a stronger
type of love than then like a straight
one and I don't I don't know why they
would yeah but then they said the
stories were more because there was like
a taboo to it you could see why a
homosexual love is stronger than
heterosexual know at that age at a young
age
what tap into your younger G oh why
answer that because I want to know - I
do remember a very brief moment in my
like I guess adolescence where I thought
two guys making out was such a turn-on
yeah I love lesbian porn
but let's be important that way that you
likewise report though you say ii by me
it's not love I don't see it as love oh
but I don't see lesbianism as love them
no I mean like wait you don't think porn
is love nah dude I'm too offended by
that I'm actually offended by that
that's crazy to me
I've actually been offended for the
first time it's real joy you just enjoy
it's like I told him Santa isn't real
weightless san is real scene is real
yeah
okay all right good thank you I thought
I heard otherwise no I think it's I
think it's these girls these guys like
guys who are to like you know if you're
Kurt Russell II I don't think the young
girls like that yeah they like guys to
like look in the camera always like have
it this expression like I'm sorry
so is that they do look like I'm sorry
apologies yeah always because I
initially have that first thought to
like really really it was a quick
Wiimote I'm like know for sure he's
[ __ ] around right but yeah you see
how he borders his [ __ ] hilarious no
yeah it was like when I first came
across it I didn't really look at it
really well but then I noticed like wait
that's edited way all [ __ ] that's really
anything I just thought you had a greasy
camera lense really like yeah I didn't I
didn't think anyone like edited their
photos I still don't think so [ __ ] you
man thank you you had like grease you
didn't know I mean look at me emotion
I'm beautiful
I get it I don't need don't need to
God's creatures research
[Music]
you
[Music]